okay we're here we're on the air
sorry I'm a minute or two late here this
morning I hope everybody is well I'm
gonna talk a bit about the latest thing
that's been bouncing around in my head
about language learning and that is the
power of curiosity I'll talk about how
it affects my own learning I'll talk a
little bit about what I found on the
internet by googling but I think
curiosity is is a very powerful
ingredient okay how I forgot to mute my
iPad I need you I bet in order to see
the questions and then I forget to mute
it
so where I come from on this whole
curiosity thing is if I think back to
where I started which sort of triggered
my interest in language learning it was
a professor I had a McGill University
who made me very interested it very
curious about French culture French
civilization therefore at the French
language and that drove me to put so
much effort into learning French and
mastering French and it was far more
powerful than all the teaching that I
received in school triggered my
curiosity
I was curious about France about this
different country now granted in Canada
we had you know I was living in Quebec
which is also french-speaking but that
was not what triggered my curiosity what
triggered my curiosity was actually is a
very attractive book with pictures of
you know France in the 16th century 17th
century male us seeing you know what all
these things for whatever reason and we
had a very good this professor was very
witty he was he challenged us he made us
curious he made us want to learn all
right so that's kind of the beginning
and I thought of that because you know I
follow different people on Twitter and
so there's this one person who is an
English teacher a language teacher that
name is teacher a language teacher
maybe a Spanish language teacher and she
said you know the important thing in my
classroom is teaching social justice and
I thought to myself you know what
language learning has become such a big
part of my life because a professor
wasn't able to tweak my curiosity about
French language and culture which then
led me first of all to achieve success
in I wouldn't say mastering French but
achieving a certainly a high degree of
fluency in French then the confidence
that I could learn Chinese and then he
just went on and on so I was triggering
that curiosity that was a powerful
educational moment not trying to push
some teachers values to both social
justice onto students and I think a lot
of the language learning as well is
based on the idea that the teachers
gonna push something at the learner they
you know you got 25 30 kids in a
classroom they're captive you're gonna
force them to do drills or tests or
you're gonna force whatever you learned
if the language you know on your test
TEFL course on these poor guinea pigs
the key is to generate that to trigger
that curiosity and I find that it's it
happens with me for example you know I
started into Arabic and there's a lot of
explanation about the grammar and and of
course it's information overload so I
might pick out one or two things there
that I kind of understand and start to
notice and then all the rest of the
explanation that's pushed at me is lost
on me until much later on and some
repair I was reading in a book so I buy
I like to buy several different books
I'm reading his book on Arabic and they
talk about the subjunctive and of course
I've been fed information about this is
that there is a subjunctive in Arabic
and in all of these many stories that
I've listened to 30 40 50 times I never
ever noticed the subjunctive the
subjunctive in Arabic is like whereas if
you know
a cool like I want to say actually we do
our new active Akula so that you get an
a at the end of that present day so
that's the subjunctive is not very
difficult but I didn't notice it it had
been explained about me I had no
interest in that it wasn't happening for
me once I had for whatever reason all of
a sudden I was interested in that now
I'm interested so I look at huh I'm
curious and then I started noticing it
in the mini stories and every time I
hear it now I know it was it because I
became curious about it and and the best
time to learn grammar sometimes if we're
listening I'm listening to my mini
stories which have a lot of basic
grammar in them and I'm curious about a
certain structure and this doesn't have
to be in Arabic it can be in Spanish or
any language when you are curious about
this particular point of grammar that's
when you should go and look up the
explanation or look up the table not
that you'll remember it all but you are
right you are ready to receive that
information I do Google just before the
little session today
I googled on this whole question of
curiosity and there's a lot of
literature about curiosity and
apparently when we are curious our
brains change and we are again I'm not
going to try and paraphrase these
scientific you know explanations but we
are more receptive to learning so
triggering curiosity is extremely
important so here we are in our 90 day
challenge we should be using the power
of curiosity to to keep us going so it
might be curiosity about some item that
you might find in the library something
you want to hear about learn about in
the language it might be curiosity you
might be feeding that curiosity you know
like I was saying I think the other day
reading about Iran and you know the
series there Tabriz and then I looked up
under Google and so I'm curious now I
want to learn
this is curiosity and initially when
when we get a lot of information pushed
us it's very difficult to sort through
there you know or to try to retain
anything and there's too much for us to
be curious about it but the other thing
that happens is as we pick up little
bits of information as I have in the
case of Arabic got a sense of some of
the things that you know how masculine
feminine works and and this kind of
thing then I'm now ready to show to have
an interest in something else and so you
know cultivating that curiosity and and
then also not being frustrated that
certain aspects of the language which
we're not yet curious about we don't yet
understand we aren't able to use it
doesn't really matter there's a gradual
gradual process
I should add in terms of curiosity I
also find that if I listen to something
and there are lots of words there that I
don't understand or even a few that I
don't understand that again tweaks my
curiosity so you know if I go from my
listening or a lot of stuff was fuzzy
then I'm very curious to read it and
then I'm more receptive to learning
those words or phrases in fact in many
ways I think our playlist and and I
think a lot of people don't use the
playlist study a lesson put it on the
playlist because the first time you
study the lesson there's so much stuff
that you won't remember and then you
listen to it and the listening is so
easy to do I can do it wherever I am and
I'd like to get in and I've said this
for which you're maybe emphasize listing
more or it get in an hour a day wherever
you are and then while you're listening
you're kind of folded fading in and out
but those things that you're curious
about you're gonna fade into
occasionally fade into like for example
the subjunctive but then you will also
trigger this curiosity about the content
and therefore you want to go and study
the lesson so the playlist the audio the
things that we can easily find time to
listen to are triggering our curiosity
about the actual you know text wanting
to
the text and review the words in that
regard I'm having some discussion with
mark about the playlist and there's been
some comment about how we should make
the playlist better more flexible
unlimited and all this kind of stuff one
of the problems in a system like Lync is
that there's so much functionality that
a large number of people are totally
confused and so therefore the more
functionality we add the more options
you can add you can have you know
folders or albums in your playlist and
you can do this and you can do that
the more settings and functions the more
people get confused so there's always a
sort of a tug back and forth like how
much complexity we want to introduce in
order to satisfy a certain portion of
our users when in fact we might just be
confusing a much larger number of our
users the bigger problem is that a lot
of people don't know the playlist this
the playlist is very important because
that's how you track your listening and
it's important to have a record of your
listening how much have you listened to
this week how much have you listened
since you started learning the language
it's an important statistic to have you
can only track it if you listen in the
left SN or on the playlist if you
download some audio and put it into
iTunes and listen away from link you
aren't then generating these statistics
anyway we were talking back and forth
personally I would like the ability to
be able to listen if I have a course
like many stories I want to be able to
listen to lesson three four five six
seven eight in sequence because when I'm
away I'm in the gym or I'm doing
something I don't want to have to go
back each time to the lesson to move to
the next lesson to listen to the next
lesson now we have the ability to set
the lesson so that it repeats so we can
listen to the same lesson over and over
again we don't have the ability to set
the course so that it'll automatically
go to the next lesson the next lesson so
you can do either a repeat scenario or
sequentially proceed in the course oh I
wouldn't mind seeing dyad in there the
question is then how do we introduce
that how do we explain that so it
doesn't confuse people so you know
those are some of the issues that we
struggle with any comments people had
would be welcome just I thought I might
just share the screen here just a little
bit to delve into this whole area of
curiosity and how it applies to to
language learning in general and to link
in particular so I am going to share my
screen so let's see start of Scripture
and I don't know whether this present to
everyone is necessary but whatever I
clicked on so here we have the lessons
if we go to the library in Spanish and
because I don't think Arabic is that
widely studied so I go to Spanish so
here again I have my lesson feed so are
there things in here that you know
there's such a variety even within
within our own library so you might want
to do many stories you might want to
read my book in Spanish okay about how I
learned languages you might want to do
Xaro you might want to you know do some
news items you know this does videos
kind of cheeky little theater group a
third we stop maybe that's an interest
so there is quite a variety of things
that you can study in terms of you know
catering to your curiosity so if we look
at my book for the sake of argument then
we open that and so one of the things
that's that's now available I said that
you know we should yeah okay so see by
okay it's easy to go right okay go
always a correct answer
yeah so with that now we have as a
grammatical explanation so if you're
curious about a verb you know it tells
you it's from here it's a self until
present that you can go and actually not
curious like how does this work you can
go to verb in our
we have a grandma resources now in a
number of languages you should be aware
of that if you go to your profile here
grammar guide it's not in every language
but a lot of languages have them and so
then you can read a quick overview and
these grammar guides we've done them as
simple as possible so these are
abbreviated overviews of the grammar but
it gives you a chance at a moment when
you are interested that you can go in
and have a quick look and then quickly
retreat back to your text so while you
are curious about something you lock it
up
I am snoring I did mention the the
playlist so you know a lot of people
don't know it's there a lot of you don't
even know that there are these different
you know you can view the course you can
manually add to your reading and
listening totals although many people
don't do that or you can add this to the
playlist it's that simple so you should
make sure and add it to the place so
again I just advise you to add your
audio to the playlist because that's
helping to generate that curiosity
you're listening sometimes fading in and
out but then there are questions that
arise in your brain questions about
vocabulary questions about grammar then
you want to go to the lesson read it if
you come across a verb or something and
you are you're curious about the grammar
you can look up and and the grammar you
can look it up by nouns by adjectives
quickly review something while that sort
of moment of curiosity is there so
that's kind of what I wanted to say on
curiosity and yeah now let's see what
sorts of question and sweet hath alright
now I see here by the way very fast ok I
will slow down that's a time what's up
my language are different mostly reading
in Spanish I'm telling you
okay now these are just chit chats the
last couple of the audio is glitchy I
don't know what to do about that how to
learn
easily there is no easily you have to
all languages are learned in the same
way
lots of listing in rediem Oh fuzzy room
live and Portuguese we could do that I
know basic or probably Steve is marked
back from his vacation no but mark is
coming down to Palm Springs tomorrow and
will chat with him there huh
this business of my connection we'll
have to look into it I don't know why
that would be I got a deal a Spanish
subjunctive okay well again how the deal
is managed objective first all you have
to be curious about it and you have to
start noticing when you see it or hear
it and you have to go to the explanation
again and solely you'll get a sense of
how that works how can we be curious at
the beginning okay no at the beginning
it's difficult to be curious the points
are in my own experience there's so much
new information I mean we have to be
curious about the language so I have to
be curious about Arabic or Persian than
our culture and I have to have that
level of curiosity but then about the
specifics of the language at first
there's so much information that we can
only really focus in on one or two
that's part of the problem with teachers
think they're going to teach you the
basics there's too much it's too much so
a lot of it goes in one ear and out the
other but eventually you get better do
you have any specific advice learning a
language for people who are dyslexic the
editors from folks here here for you um
I think that linic I think that the
reading is very closely related to
listening and there's all kinds of
research that shows and therefore if you
have if you have
listen to something many times then it
should become easier to read because you
are
it's like when I decipher I'm Dyslexic
in Arabic because I tried to decipher
the words and how jump to conclusions as
to what the word is and they're totally
wrong because easier to guess it the
word and I have trouble reading the
individual letters because they you know
it's not so consistent as to how you
pronounce them however if I have
listened to the lesson and then I also
have text-to-speech available all of
that is helping me decipher the Arabic
and slowly building up confidence in
reading and I would be very curious to
see if something like linked with the
natural voice audio which you can listen
to a few times build up your curiosity
build up your momentum then the ability
when you again confront the world and
you got it wrong but you can press
text-to-speech and hear it whether all
of that doesn't gradually ease us into
reading and into reading more and more
and the more we do anything the better
we get it and I mean I would be very
interested if people who are struggling
readers whether this kind of approach
would also be applicable to people who
have dyslexia or other difficulties in
reading fast fast fast cake kiss okay
hey Steven I didn't know okay so
Gustavo you know you know know pour the
reservoir is the customer a key the
problem here getting out to link on his
cell phone you have to cause I think
entire customer service at link 10 you
think I'll go and fellow seller
manahan's ago so it looks like there is
a problem with Eric if you're listening
there seems to be a problem with
cellular loser users accessing link so a
iOS or Android okay
let's follow up on that who writes the
grammar is
versus we Commission different people
for different languages I think you went
to an online outsourcing site and found
people and reviewed what they did and
found found people who were good at it
so it's a very much sort of concise you
know I think we said maximum six
thousand words grammar so who wrote okay
no no no are there going to be grammars
or all the language on the government
actually if there's we haven't had any
response so it's difficult for us to
keep doing things and when we get little
feedback so if people come back to us to
say I really like these grammar
resources can you do it for language X
then that motivates us to do that how
far do you think they'll learn or need
to go when it comes to grammar
well grammar in other words
understanding how the language works is
important you have to understand how the
grammar works everybody wants to speak
correctly everybody wants to speak
whether and a large part of learning to
speak correctly is simply listening and
reading so that your brain will get used
to the language and the brain will
notice many things but some things the
brain long others and that's why you
look at grammar from time to time and it
describes something that you kind of
have half noticed or maybe didn't notice
at all and after having read this
explanation then you become curious and
you start to notice it and through that
process gradually you begin to speak
more and more correctly and and we all
want to speak as correctly as we can and
yet I know many fluent speakers of
English who regularly make the same
mistakes so it's not the end of the
world but I think we all aspire to speak
more and more correctly again how do you
guys battle with all the copyright
content going on the link said I've seen
tons of content originating from other
sources there well if you see content
that seems to be you know copyrighted
please let us know in some cases some of
these sites like I can't remember in
Spanish they a
let us use the material but if there is
material though we have to ask them for
permission and if they don't agree we
remove it we do not police it all the
time because there's content being added
all the time but if anybody points out
material that shouldn't be that we
remove it I'm just trying to learn my
photography Japanese wish me stamina yes
in sensitise I wish you Stan what our
big book do you use I have a number of
Arabic books my main source has been the
are many stories but I bought a teach
yourself I bought an Arabic for dummies
I bought a simila I bought there is a
Manuel de la Motte down French port and
the Herricks is also French can you add
context reversal in German for French
speakers on link I will Eric again if
you're listening make a note of that we
can contact our guy our virtual
assistant and we can do that yes please
let us know if you would like
dictionaries at it have you ever done
any ancient languages well we do have
Hebrew and Latin what every book are you
using teachers of SML I mean I've used
them all hello from Latvia mr. Steve
lastly I've been to Riga enjoyed it very
much now that you learned the
subjunctive
would you consider reading with haricot
yeah I mean I have seen the passing
describe I don't read with haricot
because the bulk of the stuff that I
read
doesn't have Erica like these are all
little diacritics they'll help you with
the pronunciation so if I now go to a
podcast from France Batcopter al Jazeera
and I put it on my you know a
transcription automatic transcription
service what I get back doesn't have
Chanukah so I basically have avoided
Chanukah if I don't know how to
pronounce
where I use text-to-speech ah that's not
but I can't speak of course this is
Hobbit Manabe yeah I mean you have to
continue doing that and you have to
start speaking a lot of listening and
reading builds up your vocabulary but at
some point you have to start speaking
and when you start speaking it's going
to be difficult and only by speaking
more when you speak better and also
don't worry don't worry about your
problems give yourself credit for what
you're able to do so those days they are
Kathina I was in Buenos Aires and and
dohsa and he goes ooh and had a great
time okay thank you for your Korean bit
yes you mentioned that you exercise
about listening I tried that a few days
ago and it does wonders listening gets
me both to exercise and vice-versa
absolutely I think this is such a big
deal that and we don't have to be
totally focused all the time but if we
can develop the habit of listening while
doing other things cleaning the house
exercising we get a double benefit we
listen more and yet we clean the house
more or we exercise more and and I find
that it's I'm not able just to sit down
and listen sit in the chair and listen I
can't do that but if I'm doing something
else I can listen so I think it's
important I somehow I think we should
stress listening more at length I think
people should get in an hour a day two
hours a day of listening depending on
some ways what investments in technology
would you like to see to aid in language
learning I mean what I would most like
to see in language learning is I would
like to see see there is not enough for
example in Arabic intermediate content I
think generally there is a lack of
intermediate content if people would
simply create talk to each other in
their native language and transcribe it
or maybe we put it up on that
transcription service get because
typically
conversation it's easier there's fewer
difficult words and that helps bridge
the gap casual conversation takes you
then to the next level two things I
would like to see I would like to see
casual conversations transcribed and I
would like to see non fictional history
but slightly simplified I'm not so keen
on simplified stories so that strikes me
as kind of artificial but simplified
explanations of the history of Persia
the history of you know Iraq in my case
studying Arabic the history of Morocco
is
you know even you know a little fears of
its pain I all stuff that order our
world before Islam and all that stuff if
it were somehow you know a history of
Arab civilization in 20 lessons
simplified I would be all over that and
with audio like audio and text and in
other languages as well you know
nonfiction history geography kind of
stuff somewhat simplified and casual
conversations audio and text tonight if
we had like an explosion of that kind of
content that would probably do more for
language learning than any specific
technological change how would you
recommend for trying to speak while
visiting a foreign country on how to
have the most opportunity so you can get
the most out of use in a foreign country
very difficult essentially you have to
work on your comprehension on your
vocabulary as much as possible before
you go so I visited Portugal once I had
spent three or four months at that time
we didn't have Portuguese at length so I
listened to the living language I listen
to whatever I was able to get a hold up
went to Portugal and everybody asks for
being English but I was basically enable
capable of using the language there so
then I said the next time I go I'm gonna
work a bit harder but I think and we had
Portuguese uplink and so I just did a
lot more listening got my self to the
point all right listen
literally to over a hundred hours of
these Portuguese
from Radio Portugal so I was really into
the language and the second time I went
to Portugal people would speak to me in
Portuguese so that the secret is to get
your level up to the point where more
and more people will speak to you in the
language now in terms of arranging for
people to talk to I mean it depends on
the country but in countries where taxis
are cheap taxi drivers are great
teachers sit in the front and talk and
so if it's a $5 $10 taxi ride for 30
minutes you get that much you know
language instruction I visited Prague
and I have teachers there and I arranged
twice a day to be with the teacher
because you can't just with all the
respect of any you can't just randomly
approach people and expect them to talk
to you
that's not common you can walk into a
store hope they talk to you in the
language the most reliable you know
people have talked to a continent taxi
drivers
so I guess try to organize that ahead of
time if you have friends there and make
sure you're as well prepared as possible
before you get better Brisbane you're
converted mp4 and mp3s for you something
for you explain how you do that okay I
have a thing called mp3 converter free
alright um I wonder if I can demonstrate
it uh let's see here
I'm gonna try and demonstrate that we'll
see if this works done okay so I'm gonna
share this screen here start just and
sure oh that's not gonna work let's see
what happens if I do this now bear with
me here okay
I hope everyone can see this let's see
this hasn't caught off yet okay so here
are my podcasts okay
so here's a podcast in Arabic this guy
here let's say so I take this and I
slide it down onto my mp3 free converter
so this thing is now converting this to
mp3 so the podcast is that not is a
video the podcast should have explained
that the podcast is a video this one is
from Al Jazeera and so then it converts
into mp3 file no little bit confused
here
no this is kinda confusing and then what
have I done here okay where did that guy
go hmm where did my file go okay that
click was to indicate that it's complete
now because of the file sharing I'm sort
of messing up pretty badly here I don't
want this one let's see if I can find it
so here we are okay so here I have it's
been converted right so what I do is I
click on it and it'll show up here where
are we today at 10:33 this is the file
this guy I don't need anymore
so I can get this guy and this is today
at 10:33
what I do I don't know whether I need to
do this or not but I take this file and
I park it over here in my oh well it
already is the point is that park it in
my desktop and then I take that and I go
to a vocal Matic and I take that file
put it on vocal moderate and it gets
transcribed and I have an account with
some it sure
that's all I think I probably thoroughly
confused everyone but let me see if I
can get back to where I was this this
stop okay now presumably that confused
everyone but mp3 mp3 converter maybe
Google and you'll find it that is how I
convert my mp4 files to mp3 files
alright that was a good workout too well
here how many months into your full-time
Chinese study did you start to feel
comfortable comfortable comfortable
takes a long time I mean I eight or nine
months I was helping Canadian
businessmen in China the Kent on trade
fair interpreted more or less well
number Philly you know this idea that
you gonna somehow automatically you feel
comfortable you always feel a little
uncomfortable you always feel that you
could have done better you always
struggle a bit but I was translating and
interpreting after eight or nine months
do you know the time Isaac language its
North Avenue Lang and it is language of
the Berber people I heard of it I met
people spoke it but I don't know
anything about it which dialect America
did you learn recommend I have a phrase
book that teaches Egyptian supposedly
one of the most widespread understood
yeah I struggle with this you know
ultimately I decided to learn modern
Standard Arabic know all kinds of people
advise alert loving teen Egyptian stop
but I live in Vancouver I am limited
opportunity to speak Arabic if you if I
find if I look for resources online
there overwhelmingly in modern Standard
Arabic a large part of my interaction
with the Arabic language is listening
and reading and therefore the resources
for listening and reading in modern
Standard Arabic are far more available
all these interviews on al-jazeera panel
discussions interviews whatever news
articles podcasts they're all in modern
Standard Arabic I am convinced that and
I have
we have it laying some of them in Arabic
and I listen to it listen to some Egypt
[ __ ] in Arabic if I were to go and
visit you know Jordan or Lebanon or
Egypt and I had to learn some local I
think I could at least understand and I
could do that pretty quickly and even in
Morocco where the dialect is very
different I was able to have
conversations with taxi drivers in
modern Standard Arabic all Arabic school
children learn modern Standard Arabic so
theoretically any educated persons
understands modern Standard Arabic so
that was my strategy but obviously if
someone is gonna work in the Gulf or
work in Lebanon or whatever then they
will adopt a different strategy is it
cross the import comic books the future
since I'll agree them in my target
language as long as it can the text can
be you know converted into a digital
format and then the answer should be yes
I don't know much about comic books so I
can't give you more of an answer than
that any good Japanese literature for
Advanced Learner's you recommend what
materials did you use for Japanese
reading practice well I mean I was in
Japan I was reading newspapers every day
and you know I bought books in Japan I
just buy books and read them and for
Advanced Learner's I mean I you know I
would do what I did for polish I would
look up ebooks for which audiobooks are
available even if I buy them so I have a
matching ebook and audiobook I import
the e-book into link and I listen to the
audiobook I don't try and match the
audio to each lesson because that's so
much work it's not work I can't give you
any better advice than that
it's doing for you okay don't try to
imitate native speakers because they
don't speak correctly
um yeah in every language there are
native speakers who make mistakes but if
you can speak as well as a native
speaker you're doing fine
who else you gonna listen to because the
native speaker typically speaks more
correctly or let's play this play
different native speakers are influenced
by the language as it is spoken around
them so there are lots of people now who
say less cars instead of fewer cars
there's lots of people say I would have
what meant instead of I would have gone
and so if there are a lot of people
around them who speak that way then that
so-called incorrect form of the language
will grow and draw and may one day
become standard usage you cannot do
better than to listen to a native
speaker in my opinion hg1 is a lot of
difficult tense of French or what would
you say is in a different part of
learning French I mean I think people
get too worked up over tenses it's going
to be difficult in all of Romance
languages to get the you know the verb
endings right every time I think
personally the difficulty in French is
that the way the language through you
know the LEAs known from one word to the
next makes it more difficult to to
listen to understand when you're
listening than say Spanish but every
language has its difficulties and I see
it as as yeah I don't know I can't tell
you the answer because I let I learn my
friends through so much listening ready
it's not like when I learned slamming
languages I quickly identified that you
know case endings verbs of motion and
aspects of verbs were the most difficult
issues in French I have no idea how
should I start to start in Chinese okay
I think a nice tip here is some
vocalizing useful or you have a native
like you're married or should be stopped
everybody some vocalizes I think to some
extent and we're learning a foreign
language that's one of the reasons why I
think it's so important to listen a lot
and you will gradually have a better a
better sense of how the words are
pronounced while your stuff vocalizing
what what motivates you to learn a
language changes after what if yeah I
mean if you lose interest in the
language then you got to go off to
something else how hard should you start
trying Chinese the only difference
between
Chinese and other languages is that you
need to put in my opinion emphasis on
learning the characters which is a lot
of work so when do I start listening
without a transcription there just comes
a point where I'm comfortable listening
and it's just too much trouble to go and
work for the transcription because I
feel there's so few words in there that
I didn't understand that I don't want to
read it I enjoy listening and I'm
learning by listening if I'm really
curious about something I might you know
get it transcribed most cases I am stead
of not today
Saturday May 3 it comes a point where
the listening and readings diverges so I
will I will read on link and pick up
some vocabulary that way and I just
listen you know separate from any and
the transcript suppose you're already
relatively fluent language in your
experience how many links per page would
be too many in the sense that maybe the
material is too complex for you well you
know what I think that 10 to 15 percent
is a good level is there's only a few
percent it's almost not worth it
once you get over 15 percent it's
getting you difficult I would say max 20
percent no there in mind that depending
on on what material you're studying some
of that may be you know place names
proper names so the 20 percent is really
15 percent but somewhere in that range
10 to 20 percent is kind of the the
sweet spot in terms of learning sewers
and yet not being overwhelmed do I
actively listen to music no I don't know
I don't just a cure are you interested
in philosophy have you ever thought to
introduce this subject to link I mean
most of our content is provided by
others so if people put philosophy texts
there then that's what there will be
there and there are people who are
interested in philosophy I am to a small
extent but I'm more interested in in
history literature
of all girls in your regard amazing
precioso video thank you girl you so
cool let's thank you and blah blah blah
helene with the fedora yeah yeah I think
do you find that when learning Spanish
it's hard for the brain to adjust to
recognize the subject of the sentence
conjugations reviews and not subjects no
but I think that as in anything in a new
language it takes us time to get used to
it it takes us time for that to be
natural because our brains are
conditioned to learn in order to manage
our own language therefore say English
speakers speaking Spanish we'll always
want to put the proton on in there you
know yo yo yo iiiii
whereas in Spanish and many other
languages the personal pronoun is often
omitted you just gradually get used to
it you know learning language is is
learning to imitate sort of the behavior
of a different cultural group and that
includes these sort of patterns of the
language you gradually get better and
better than imitating that behavior many
probably a father a teacher do can you
focus on teaching well I mean to me
teaching and I have never been a
classroom teacher but teaching is to me
is how about turning on the learners
easier said than done if you've got 25
more or less distracted kids in that
classroom but somehow you I would like
to find some way to trigger the
curiosity the the interest the
motivation and then allow them to come
to me when they have a question a
question about the language of question
about the country a question about it
try and trigger try and make them come
to me for what they're interested in
rather than me deciding for them today
we're gonna do the subjunctive
test two on the subjunctive whether you
like it or not and then we'll consider
the subjunctive is not done you're
supposed to know it and then move to the
conditional somehow I feel that teachers
have got a triggered that like happened
to me with my French teacher triggered
that interest in the subject in some
aspect of it not don't they love
everything but that's again why if the
teacher says you know you should be
interested in French films and the
learners that I'm not interested in
French jobs so you have to define things
that they're interested in and people
here talking about comics or manga anime
or whatever it might be let them find
those things that interest them in fact
if I wouldn't like in Canada everybody
has to learn French well what if the kid
doesn't want to learn French
there's be more freedom to learn
whatever language interest them because
there's so much content there's so many
resources available you don't have to
have a certified teacher of French or
Chinese in fact we should have which is
certified teachers as language learning
coaches who know how to stimulate the
learner trigger their curiosity and then
help them find the resources that they
need in whatever language they're
interested in that X micron um teaching
whether with our community Drake
okay and so the KATUSA says that her
teacher says that learning languages is
linear and not gradual I don't quite
understand but I think learning
languages is a very fuzzy process we
don't build on the basic building blocks
the basic sort of the basics of the
language
it sort of comes at us it's it's not
obvious that the present is easier than
the past tense that there's any
particular order the brain sorts out the
order in which it's going to remember
certain things or get used to certain
structures and therefore all we really
need to do is to make sure that we
expose ourselves as to as much content
as possible hopefully not too difficult
comprehensible is important like where
you have a chance of understanding 60 70
80 percent of it where you're interested
in it and as long as you feed the brain
enough of this kind of material and then
when you're curious about a point of
grammar look it up that we will
gradually learn now is that a linear
process I don't see it so much as a
linear process I'm studying English but
what is the secret to speak fluently
speak more all right
the secret diplomacy is a good
comprehension because you have to speak
a lot speak with people if you don't
understand what they're saying
you can't maintain a conversation so
build up your comprehension skills your
vocabulary and then speak a lot and
don't worry about how well you do know
there's your workbook everybody very
well have you been able to put the air
five Habits of Highly Effective People
on a link huh what happened with that
seven Habits it was and no I wasn't able
because I couldn't this term Oscar I
couldn't get a form of the text first of
all I can't put it on me to share but
even for my own you
the e-book that I bought and paid for
his DRM protected or something in any
case I gave up on that I have the audio
book I would love to be able to study
the e-book on length but I haven't been
able to convert it in the format that I
can use but at any rate I couldn't share
it if you want to learn traditional - is
it better let's start off with
simplified first know if you want to
learn traditional start with traditional
even like when we learn I learned
traditional first and then learned it's
easier to go from traditional to
simplified than the other way around
that's who my advice now it may be the
dessert kind of evidence that that the
reverse is true I don't know he's
reading nonfiction now that languages
such as Anthony beaver second were
better than children's stories it is to
me
far better far better first of all
translations typically use less you know
difficult words like the tendon
translators tend to use you know higher
frequency words so translations are
always easier second of all if you're
reading the history of the Second World
War or presumably you're interested so
that's good presumably you know
something about the subject so that's
good children's stories like I have no
interest children's stories introduced
vocab you like the bird the rabbit then
all kinds of stuff that's maybe not that
relevant or high frequency and I have I
have always preferred history history
and translation simplified history to
children's stories miscarriage on
yesterday vice versa we're gonna I'm
just watching your lack of a hello from
Brazil says which is the best fit for
learning language and what do you think
about memory palace okay
I am NOT I am NOT into the memory palace
that I think I have never been willing
to put the effort into developing these
mnemonic tricks and stuff like that it
may work for people I don't use them so
I can't comment you know best app for
learning languages
I'm prejudiced I am involved with link
and I use Lake so to me that's the best
at his German missing some mini stories
yes now in German not again we rely we
have rely on volunteers to help us
translate and record these many stories
we have had a better response as some
languages than others in some cases we
have had to pay to have them done if
there is strong demand for the
additional many stories in German we can
also pay to have them done we are
waiting for you no volunteers who
promised to do them and they haven't
done them but Johan if you're interested
and if others are interested and I know
you have talked it up on the forum then
we that kind of forces us to do
something yeah all right I'm gonna leave
here as well I've got a run I have an
Arabic class starting at 11:00 all right
thank you and bye for now